the present ideas about gender identity
are quite reactionary and they sort of
go along the lines of if you are sex
non-conforming maybe you're you're in
the wrong sex
[Music]
Kathleen stock welcome to how the light
gets in thank you for having me so
you've become sort of famous for your
views on gender identity and the
relationship between trans identity and
female identity and I wanted to start
with some kind of basic distinctions in
this debate so the relevant to section
that has come to Define it this debate
over the identity of trans people is on
the one hand sex on the other hand
gender the first one is supposed to
denote the sort of biological
physiological makeup of people and the
second one is meant to recognize a kind
of social identity and a social role
that people play and the claim is that
those two things can sort of become
untethered from one another what's your
view on this distinction and do you do
you accept that kind of fundamental
distinction I wouldn't put it quite that
way to be honest it's certainly not
where the present discourse is
um the sex bit was fine the gender bit
is spiraling off in something that's
actually not very social at all it's
supposed to to be psychological it's
supposed to be individual and it's
nothing really to do with how you're
perceived by others so it's not social
in that sense it's to do with how you
feel now obviously I think there's a
social explanation for how people feel
but it's not construed as social so in
other words the
kind of definition of gender that we got
in the 1970s
um to some extent partly from feminists
partly from psychologists working with
people with differences of sexual
development and that that was a social
idea of a role like that was Associated
either masculinity or femininity and
those things can come apart from sex
like you could get females that are
masculine and and males are feminine but
then that sort of some somewhere around
this Century
got tumblrized into it's in your head
it's an identity and you know we don't
need to explain where it came from in
fact now people think it's innate the
new story is it's part of you a central
part of who you are that's got to come
out at some point and that's a whole
different uh distinction to the original
one so so you so this is the the bit as
aware of that you kind of gender
politics that you kind of find
problematic the idea that it's somehow a
private mental state that defines your
gender identity not this kind of social
role that you play well I wouldn't care
at all if people weren't trying to reify
it into law and policy right I have no
idea no no problem with people saying
that they are one thing or the other or
acting in any way or altering their
bodies if that's how they feel but
um through quite powerful institutions
and and it's happening internationally
actually
um there's this idea that your inner
gender identity which can come
completely apart from your sex and your
gender expression even in the old sense
should determine your rights and access
to spaces or resources or sports teams
or rate crisis shelters or whatever now
that obviously poses a problem
particularly for females uh I think
um because it allows males to basically
say they have this private state that
nobody can tell them they don't have
built into the policies you know it's
all part of the rhetoric that nobody can
tell you that you don't have the
identity that you think you do
so and and as soon as you say you've got
that identity you've got it so you then
get access to all these things and in
the and that you know we can go into the
problem but I think there are some
problems there
um so if if we were still as it were in
the 1970s era of like where we thought
of gender as this kind of social
expression of identity
um would that be okay to sort of be
formalized in kind of law to to separate
biological sex from gender expression we
and kind of make it concrete that that's
kind of recognized by law if we were to
go back and start again it's a I think
it is a good question what laws we'd
want but I certainly think we should
always have some kind of law that
affects uh sorry that um protects uh
what you might call gender
non-conforming people I would say sex
non-conforming because this word gems
just got so polluted
um from discrimination so that would
cover men who want to dress like women
or change their bodies to look like
women or and women who want to look like
men and lesbians and gays and all sorts
of things you know nobody should be
discriminated against for being sex
non-conforming and I totally have never
obviously I'm not a sex particularly sex
performing myself so but and it's not
just a selfish move I just don't think
that there's any problem with those
sorts of laws but that's not where we
are in fact
you know if anything everything's got so
messed up that um the present ideas
about gender identity are quite
reactionary
um and they sort of go along the lines
of if you are sex non-conforming maybe
you're you're in the wrong sex
and that's quite reactionary to me
you've often said that your position on
this issue of gender identity and and
the status of trans people gets
misconstrued or misunderstoods can you
tell me what some of the main ways your
viewers misunderstood
well it's not hard is it I mean it the
debate the public debate is set up so
that any criticism at all of the idea of
gender identity is construed as
transphobic so there's this kind of ad
hominem move to my character
my motives my intentions all the rest of
his most it's the crudest kind of uh
it's not intellectual and the slightest
it's just like she must be a bad person
because that's the only reason she could
have any problem with any of this so
yeah in that context then people will
start spinning all sorts of lies about
my position what I'm committed to but
I'm not committed to
um she wants to take away try the rights
of trans people is the about us
bold as it gets and obviously I don't
but there is some discussion to be had
about what rights means in our country
you know and is it the right of a male
to save a woman and go into a sports
team I would say not but is it a right
to be protected from discrimination yes
it is so then you have to ask what
discrimination is you know so it I don't
think there's any kind of subtle
um misinterpretation of me going on the
people that have a vested interest in
misinterpreting me
um don't want me to succeed obviously
they don't want me to win this argument
in fact they don't want me to have it at
all as you you can see one fundamental
claim is that trans women are women from
the kind of other side as aware of the
debate and you claim trans women aren't
really women trans women men aren't
really men and that when people make
those claims they have a kind of status
of fiction can you tell us exactly what
you mean by that what you mean by
fiction here
what I mean by fiction
um I mean they're immersing themselves
so fiction I take it that we can
um get involved in fictions or we do all
the time we're just in dramas at the
theater watching telly reading books you
know we can imaginatively position
ourselves in certain States it also
happens when you're acting
um I think it's a a basic human capacity
and I think when people for well-meaning
reasons or otherwise go say trans women
are literally women there's no
difference between a woman and a trans
woman or at least no relevant difference
I think they are immersing themselves in
a fiction and that's quite a charitable
explanation to be honest because if they
really believe that then there's
something gone wrong with their beliefs
because the standard categorizations of
woman and man relate to sex and always
have in every natural language because
every natural language needs a
differentiation between the females and
the males and the adults and the young I
guess some people have taken your have
taken offense at this sort of claim as
they interpret it basically as you
saying that trans people don't really
exist right well they are a fiction like
just the usual bad faith interpretation
but tell me what the difference is
between saying that Sherlock Holmes is a
fictitious character as a fiction or
Santa Claus is a fiction
they exist in certain contexts they're
the difference is that I'm not saying
trans people are a fiction they're
people who exist not mad
um I'm saying the best analysis of the
claim is that people make about trans
people and that sometimes people make
about themselves not all trans people by
the way I know plenty of trans people
say like I know plenty of trans women
who say I'm a man so
I'm saying that if you say I'm a woman
knowing or I say of a trans woman she's
a woman knowing their sex nature I think
it's a charitable explanation of what's
going on there linguistically that they
are
in a fiction but it's not it's not
anything to do with this status of trans
people as existence
but the idea but the identity is in
question here right so the identity
itself isn't real
the identity well it depends what you
mean by identity
um and what you mean by real
um if identities can be like like issued
out of imaginative States then they're
real but should we
is the question of priorities right
should we automatically capitulate to
these identity statements uh socially
and politically every time they're made
or are there other identities in a
probably a more materialistic sense
because you know identity used to mean
the thing that people saw you as as well
as the thing you felt you were that's
all gone out the window it's just how
you feel inside now so there are other
identities that trans people also have
they're humans they you know and they're
male or female and those identities
sometimes they may not they may not
identify with them but they are still
relevant in some cases to where they
should go in Social space or whatever it
is but one of the cases where there is
that sort of social recognition so when
some person is socially recognized as
being a woman is not treated differently
in most social circumstances any
different to if they were born a woman
what do we make of it then isn't that
then a kind of confirmation confirmation
of the fact that they're women yeah well
no because a woman isn't an appearance
it's not just appearance it's a
recognition of a certain State yes but
that's just like
no offense but that's kind of middle
class academic word games because
in every natural language the woman is
the sexually mature female and it
doesn't matter how they look and do we
really want a world in which the women
have to look according to a certain set
of social prescriptions and you know how
how glamorous do they have to be how
feminine you know it's just nonsense
right so you want to make free of all
that we want to say there are men and
the women and they can look any way they
like but there is a question about you
know in terms of practicality for trans
women for instance or trans men if they
have taken you know gone through loads
of surgery taken loads of hormones and
have completely altered their opinion so
they do like look like the opposite sex
like that's a question about you know
how they
is obviously very awkward for to ask a
passing transsexual to use the um
facilities of their own sex in my book I
say
fine there's nothing we could do about
that and it would be awkward
um
I think we should have third spaces
where possible but that's really more
for people who don't look like their
identity because they're the ones that
disrupt all the social norms like we
just can't have a situation where a male
who looks like a male can walk into a
woman's bathroom or changing room or
whatever
and say I belong here
because then anyone can basically what
makes that space so it's complicated so
I don't I completely deny the um trans
women are not women trans men are not
men I know that's terrible for everyone
to hear but I just think it's true
um but that still doesn't settle the
question of what happens politically and
socially for people who have genuinely
you know socially transitioned but in
some ways isn't that the Crux of the
issue right so we might never come to
agree about the kind of metaphysical
status of
or you know the kind of you know social
status of women and they're just
genuinely is a disagreement there and
we're probably never going to convince
each other as it were and so then the
question becomes what is the stage is
what's the state supposed to do and
what's the role of the stage that's the
certainly my entry point because I
wouldn't have got involved in this just
for the sake of it I'm not interested in
going up to people and telling they're
not you know that I disagree with their
own understanding themselves but that's
not what we were where we were at self
ID was coming down the line in 2015 it's
still coming down the line in Germany
um it's already here in other countries
um Spain it's coming so it's a live
issue and then we have to think of
solutions because we can't just have it
um according to the the lobbying groups
they're trying to push through this very
radical
um is that policies
so to go back to the
um sort of issue of bathrooms and other
women's spaces uh female prisons for
example and things like that right that
one of the arguments that these trans
trans women should be potentially
excluded from those spaces because they
might be kind of the physical threat to
women but on the other hand the argument
is well that that may be but these
people would be even more vulnerable if
they were to use say male toilets or
bathrooms or be sent to a male prison so
what do we do in those we have
alternative Services quite obviously and
there's a ton of money in this area that
could be put into lobbying for
alternative services but in fact what we
have for instance in Brighton near where
I live is we have
um all
um Rape Crisis and uh services are
trans-inclusive none are female only so
that's in Balance there should be female
only and there should be trans inclusive
but um
I was just going to go back to that
point about
um trans women or women that's it does
become relevant here even though you say
it's just a kind of abstract question
because I think you'll find I mean yes
it's one of the arguments people use
that for instance trans women can't go
into male prisons because they'd be
vulnerable to violence but another
argument is they need to go into those
spaces because they're women and it's
sort of
their right as women to go where women
go so that's that's you know lots of
different arguments have pushed a
leverage to push this through but um it
doesn't it's not abstract anymore when
it's being demanded that women move up
or put themselves in potential dangerous
situations because fellow women
are um have the right to be there and
you can see that in sport you know why
is Leah Thomas swimming in a women's
competition well because she's a woman
she just looks very different to all the
other women
and she's faster
right
um
yeah I guess you know that there have
been arguments that there should be
assertion kind of rules and constraints
that have to do with sort of bodily
physiology but not necessarily with sage
and Italia right so the things like with
I don't know hormone levels or something
like that when sport yeah
um there's been all sorts of arguments I
mean at the moment self-id is the one of
the main criteria you just get to go
where you want but does that actually
happen dude yes of course it happens I
mean it's happening um
amateur level all over the place for a
start so whatever and then even at Elite
level the um ioc
have recently dropped the testosterone
reduction requirements but then they've
sort of shoved it back onto other
sporting bodies lower down the chain as
it were to make up their own rules but
no there are um and in University sports
teams there are policies that just say
sure anyone who feels like a woman can
compete in this women's event so yes it
happens
so to go back to this issue this
question of like fiction and the kind of
like what makes
um the claim that someone's a woman kind
of true I was wondering whether it's not
the case that a lot of our social
identities are sort of fictions in some
way and I have here in mind for example
adulthood right so whether we recognize
someone as an adult
in some way it's linked to a particular
age but that's almost kind of arbitrary
right it's kind of just a social
convention
it's a social convention we've decided
that at 18 people have a new legal
status and what we did in 17 and yeah
but just because there's some sort of
ambiguity around the edges doesn't mean
it's completely arbitrary so that's
that's a fallacy but
um it's not it's it's usually linked to
an attempt to get sexual maturity right
and but it yes there is ambiguity and
there's cultural variation in how people
construe adulthood but you don't find
cultures on the whole making
two-year-olds adults you know there is a
ballpark very they're in and it's it's
in a kind of well-functioning society
adulthood would be linked to
brain maturity the capacity to make
decisions some sense of autonomy and
that's not random that's linked to
development so
I don't think so so you think there are
certain hard facts in the world which
determines I think you are you're sort
of moving there between oh there's just
not some sort of observable cut-off
point that everybody
um agrees with to oh it's all totally
arbitrary and I'm saying
there's loads of things in the world
that like yes there's some kind of
vagueness in where we arrive at so
there's some social contribution but
it's not just sort of you know
um throwing some dice in the air and
seeing where they land or something it's
it's an attempt to get something right
that was already there
okay but but something is there as it
were something exactly where the world
is there yeah there are people that you
know born go through development age and
die that's not social convention
when it comes to the issue of the threat
of violence against women from men that
claim they're women
um I wanted to ask you what do you think
the sort of core driving force of
violence against women is and whether it
is somehow linked to physiology or
whether it's linked more to the kind of
social roles that you know men and women
play in society you know men are more
sort of powerful physically on average
than women and so maybe that does enable
them to maybe
um sure that enables them to act
violently against women but that's
perhaps not the cause and that's where
I'm kind of like trying to see whether
it is a social role there in everything
in the human world pretty much one of
those things exceptions you know there's
a natural contribution and there's a
social contribution so
um and it's as we've just established in
the question of adults it's hard to find
the boundaries but you know what we can
say is that males on average like other
um great ape species that we are you
know the chimps bonobos the males
um tend to be well particularly The
Chimps but nobody's a bit different but
um
powerful bigger shoulders taller longer
limbs uh bigger lungs bigger extremities
and all the rest of it obviously that's
not an essential claim
there's variation I'm six foot tall you
know but you can make generalizations
um now there's testosterone as well in
the mail and testosterone
causally predisposes males to at certain
points in the Life in particular to be
aggressive physically aggressive
depending on their situation now
societies can put in place measures to
try and protone that down you know you
can have elaborate kinds of Behavioral
codes you can have a strong cultural
state or whatever it is but you can do
things and obviously some societies are
much more violent than others but the
base level is not nothing and I think
what we're
you know it's very easy for people that
go to how the light gets in academics
not people that are really in their
bodies very much in my experience
academics to kind of get all abstract
about oh all these possible permutations
if I you know and it also it's
non-coincidentally gives academics power
because they get to construe the world
any way they want but there are facts
about males and females and they make a
difference to our social life and we
need to protect females from predatory
males so every society needs to protect
females from petitry males and it's
crazy to unpick all the good work
feminists have done since the 70s and
putting in these
domestic violence refuges and Rape
Crisis shelters on the basis of this mad
idea that a man who thinks he's a woman
is a woman
bunkers but that kind of brings us back
to the original discussion we had which
is is that the main claim that you find
problematic is this sort of like well
when it's operationalized when it's
operationalized I mean when I started
this I didn't really want to get into
well I mean like when I started
discussing it I thought I could leave
out the woman question I thought I could
just I said well they're not female
you know I I would and I would say male
Bodied
and people would say oh what a
transphobic dog whistle she said male
bodied you know did you hear it she said
a trans woman was male bodied a lot
bigger so at some point you know
anything you say adverting to the sex is
interpreted as unacceptable and at that
point I started to realize that it was
really important I'm afraid to say
trans women are not women I mean given
all the lobbying around it the t-shirts
from Stonewall you know there's been a
whole for 10 years at least there's been
propaganda pumping through our
institutions saying trans women or women
get over it and you can't get more
aggressive than that but when it comes
to male bodies I mean what what about
people that begin to not look like you
know well they're still male bodied I
mean that's the
are we talking about genitalia here what
are we talking about
what you talk about you asked the
question well I'm asking you what do you
mean by male body I mean because I mean
someone who grows you know breasts and
being on a developmental pathway
determined probably eight weeks into
conception to produce small mobile
gametes which you might then have your
testicles chopped off you might then
have artificial breasts you might then
have a penile inversion
you're still male you haven't changed
sex it would be it would be
unprecedented in the natural world we're
not clownfish you know we're not
sequential hermaphrodites we don't
change sex we can aestheticize ourselves
to look different ways and we do but
really the idea that a trans woman is a
woman because she looks like a woman
it's just teaching treating a woman as a
skin suit I mean women aren't skin suits
where is your work taking you next I
mean this was a big diversion from your
normal work on the philosophy of fiction
and Aesthetics it wasn't that big a
diversion was it because it was about
fiction so right yeah
well I'm not in the University system
anymore as you may have noticed and I'm
not going back so
um now I'm just writing for a popular
audience on various things I'm trying to
get away from all these arguments I've
made them I think they're compelling
um I'm actually more interested in how
our institutions have let this happen
and how our academic classes have let
this happen and I think there's lots of
interesting questions about that
so I'm writing for various Publications
on that sort of thing Kathleen sock
thank you very much thanks for having me
[Music]
the more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV